projection and projectile the archaic
identity of subject and object which is
the basis of the phenomenon of
projection persists subliminally as
mentioned above even in highly
cultivated men and women in the
unconscious the inner world and the
outer world are not differentiated only
that which has become a content of
consciousness is described as an inner
or an outer phenomenon that is either as
an introspectively perceived condition
like the welling up of an emotion or as
an outer event or object everything else
of which we are not conscious remains as
before an undifferentiated part of the
occurrences of life this is why as we
said at the outset one cannot speak of
projection in the strict sense until a
disturbance arises that necessitates the
revision of a merely assumed perception
or of a judgment that has been accepted
without reflection this disturbance
finds expression as doubt or uncertainty
or in a tendency to defend the previous
judgment in an unrealistic way precisely
because its credibility is already
undermined from within or without since
projection is a pre conscious
involuntary process independent of
consciousness it is to be expected that
the process itself will be depicted in
products of the unconscious such as
dreams waking fantasies and mythological
traditions this aspect will therefore be
given special attention in what follows
so that the still open question of
exactly where projections come from may
perhaps be somewhat clarified whenever
projection takes place there is first of
all a sender and a receiver
interestingly enough the motif of the
sender of the figure from whom magical
effects emanate is central to many myths
but even more frequently the motif of
the one who is hid is at the core of the
myth which may often deal with the
question of defense against such effects
these will become
here because this is an aspect of
projection that seldom receives much
attention in therapy at present one of
the oldest ways of symbolizing
projection is by means of projectiles
especially the magic arrow or shot that
harms other people the oldest
explanation for the causes of illness to
be found almost everywhere in the world
is of a projectile that affects its
target for good or ill it is generally
believed that such a projectile is shot
by a god spirit demon or some other
mythological being or by an evil person
and that it hits people and perhaps
animals as well causing them to fall ill
one is reminded of the original relation
between the German con kite illness and
Konkan - hurt or wound whether the
archer who shoots the arrow should be
regarded as inner or outer is a question
better left until the material at hand
has been examined more closely Lowrie
honk Oh in his book con kites Pawiak
tidak has supplied an abundant
collection of documentary evidence to
which we shall refer in ancient Judaism
there is the idea that God also the
devil in the New Testament and/or evil
human beings sent forth harmful arrows
in Psalm 91 there is the passage you
will not fear the terror of the night
nor the arrow that flies by day nor the
pestilence that stalks in darkness nor
the destruction that wastes at noonday
job's plague was also caused by Yahweh's
arrows for the arrows of the almighty
are in me my spirit drinks their poison
the terrors of God are arrayed against
me job chapter 6 verse 4 but the evil
harmful words of human beings are also
described as arrows deceitful men bend
their tongue like a bo falsehood and not
truth has grown strong in the land their
tongue is a deadly arrow
it speaks deceitfully Jeremiah chapter 9
verses 3 & 8
they aim bitter words like arrows
shooting from ambush at the blameless
Psalm 64 verses 3 & 4 that these
quotations refer to effective Kalume
Gnaeus activities of human beings and
that such activities as we learn from
practical psychological experience are
triggered by negative projections is
clear enough as soon as a person
projects a bit of his shadow onto
another human being he is incited to
this kind of rancorous speech the words
barbs punches that hit the other person
like projectiles symbolize the negative
flow of energy directed against the
other by the one who is projecting when
one becomes the target of another
person's negative projection one often
experiences that hatred almost
physically as a projectile it is more
difficult to understand the arrows of a
God or of God as representing
projections and yet the dispatch of
arrows bringing sickness or death is
ascribed to divine figures with special
frequency in ancient Vedic literature
the god Rudra sends death and illness
with his arrows as we read in the Rig
Veda to Rudra I bring these songs whose
bow is firm and strong with swiftly
flying shafts armed with sharp pointed
weapons may he hear our call he through
his lordship thinks on beings of the
earth on heavenly beings heal all
sickness though very gracious God has
2000 medicines inflict no evil on our
sons or progeny Rudra's arrows could
produce fever coughing malignant tumors
and stabbing pains
whereas today all these illnesses are
considered to be physical the word
Arrowhead or arrow point was also used
in the Rig Veda to indicate the cause of
purely psychic disturbances the Indic
word salya means Arrowhead thorn
splinter in one text it is said of the
doctor who removes such an object from
the body of a patient
that he is like a judge who in a trial
pulls out the thorn of injustice here
the arrow is something like a bad effect
that has led to illness out of
uncertainty about the justice of a
situation today we know that sharp
jabbing forms in the drawings of
patients indicate evil wounding
destructive impulses that stand in the
way of a synthesis of the personality
when in mythological representations
arrows of this kind are sent by gods not
by evil humans these destructive
impulses regarded psychologically are
produced by unconscious archetypal
contents Spears and arrowheads are
symbolic expressions of direction the
directedness of psychic energy as has
been established in countless drawings
by patients in the mythology of classic
antiquity apollo and artemis were
especially noted for sending death and
disease via their arrows thus apollo
sent a plague to the army attacking Troy
Iliad book 1 line 43 and following
because Agamemnon had insulted one of
his priests in Roman renderings Apollo
and Mars dispatch arrows of disease
arrows from a God however produced not
only sickness and death
sudden seizures of passionate love also
come from the arrows of the god eros
Cupid amore suddenly falling
passionately in love is also experienced
as rather like a sickness in that one
Pines away or languishes in Indian
mythology the love God kama is armed
with bow and arrow and Buddha describes
the erotic wish as an arrow but if those
sensual pleasures fail the person who
desires and wishes for them he will
suffer
pierced by the arrow of pain in late
antiquity the suspicion had already
risen that certain gods might have
something to do with the way in which
emotions work in human beings a view
that was especially furthered by
astrological speculations thus Saturn
has something to do with a melancholy
turn of my
Mars with aggression and initiative
Venus and Cupid with love and sexuality
all states of mind or moods that strike
people suddenly and overwhelmingly and
for a time can subjugate the conscious
ego the symbol of the arrow is a visual
expression of being suddenly hit by a
mood or an emotion that often strikes
one like lightning out of a blue sky the
gods are representations of certain
natural constants of the unconscious
psyche of the ways in which the
emotional and imaginative elements of
the personality behave as is well known
Jung described these constants as
archetypes these are innate a
representable structures that always and
everywhere on suitable occasions produce
similar thoughts mythological images
feelings and emotions in human beings
parallel to the instincts those impulses
to action that are characteristic of the
human species these archetypal symbol
forms were in principle assumed to exist
in a visible material or invisible
spiritual outer world but the notion
that they issued from an inner psychic
space unknown to man gradually took hold
in late antiquity this led to an
interesting new conception of human
personality that Isadora the son of the
Gnostic facilites handed down to us
namely that the human being or
alternatively his ego also possesses a
prosthesis psyche a soul that has grown
on to him and belongs to a species of
animal souls like those of wolves
monkeys and lions
these represent effective states that
seduce a man into evil deeds against his
will the Gnostic Valentinus on the other
hand
suspected that such appendages Pros
automata might also consist of the
invading spirits these spirits numata
seduced the human being into indecent
desires by the wool during him or
confusing him with images of lust as
with a fog of evil
while the animal souls tend to depict
the more instinctual aspect of the
unconscious those of the spirits and the
gods appear to represent the more
archetypal that is the more spiritual
contents of the unconscious although the
two realms overlap a good deal as to
their significance which is not
surprising in view of the close
relationship of spirit and instinct
which will be discussed later when an
archetype is immediately and intensively
constellated the experience is like
being hit by a projectile sent by an
overpowering being that transfixes us
and brings us into its power at the same
time we are assailed by fantasies and
imaginary images experienced either as
proceeding directly from the inner world
for example as an obsessive idea or more
often as caused by an outer object an
attack of aggressive hatred for example
is felt by us as coming not from Mars
but rather from an evil adversary who
deserves to be hated shadow projection
erotic passion not from Cupid but from a
woman who arouses this passion in a man
anima projection ultimately however it
appears that projections always
originate in the archetypes and in
unconscious complexes dreams can
substantiate this even more precisely
thus a woman dreamed that an unknown
figure said to her you have romantic
dreamy blue eyes the dream figure had
such eyes while the dreamer herself has
lively gray green eyes one must conclude
from this that the dream figure projects
onto the dreamers ego a quality that
belongs to the unknown figure and not to
the ego complex the unknown dream figure
however would be an as yet unconscious
partial personality a complex of the
dreamer of whose existence she has
hitherto known nothing nor apparently
does the dream figure know herself and
she therefore projects her own image
onto the dreamers
Iko probably with the intention of
inducing the ego to see herself as
dreamily romantic and thus to identify
with the complex presumably this happens
in the interest of integration when
other people project positive or
negative qualities onto us
this often produces a certain ego
insecurity we no longer know whether we
really have such splendid or such ugly
traits or not especially since there is
almost always a hook on which the
projection is home if in addition our
own unconscious complexes can cast such
projections onto our ego as the above
dream shows this can lead to a further
source of mistaken judgments by the ego
about itself sometimes it really seems
as if the wildering imaginary images
were buzzing all around one as
Democritus once expressed it as he saw
it the outer world is filled not only
with atoms but also with animated images
which he called demons or spiritual
principles these edala
or biomechanical fantasy can harm us or
help us they appear with special clarity
and dreams but also float around us
during the day as fantasy images only a
subtle Spirit says Democritus can tell
them apart whereas ordinary human beings
confuse these fantasy images with
concretely perceived objects small
wonder then that one needs a long
process of maturing and a good bit of
self-knowledge before coming to a
relatively constant ego identity and the
moderate level-headed estimate of
oneself the attribution of a psychic
content in another person's imagination
to one's own being or its rejection as
the others projection is an occasion not
only for critical thinking but also for
a feeling evaluation it can therefore
never be managed purely intellectually